- Our first Wildflower of the Season Two,
is well, out of this world.
Diana Trujillo is a
NASA Aerospace Engineer
working on the Perseverance Rover,
which is currently searching
for signs of life on Mars.
We caught up with her at the
NASA Jet Propulsion Laboratory,
just outside of LA in
Pasadena, California.
And I know that you're going
to be as blown away by her
and her backstory as we were.
There's a lot about kind of school
in the theme of this show,
so take a look at this.
Hello everybody, we are coming to you
from a very special location.
We're on Mars.
Well, actually we're on
the simulation of Mars
and we are here with our
Wildflower, Diana Trujillo.
It's your backstory
that really inspires me.
You came here from Columbia at 17.
- That's correct.
- What was your fear
and what was your dream?
- My fear there was, am I
gonna be able to eat today.
Am I gonna be able to
have the shelter today?
Where am I gonna sleep.
In my dream at the same
time was to survive.
When I was in Columbia,
and I was thinking that,
everything around me was chaotic.
Looking at the sky was the
place where I found myself.
- What a beautiful thing to turn to
in such pain and chaos and fear.
And the payoff is we're here at NASA.
(Diana laughs)
You are a leading engineer.
- I channelize my grandma,
my great-grandma, my mom,
and I realized, they really
gave up their education
for the children.
It is time for me to honor
what they did for me,
and also to show the men in my family,
that women can do more
than what they think.
I remember myself asking,
"What's the hardest thing
that a human can do?"
And then thinking, "I'm gonna do that."
- Oh my gosh.
(Diana laughs)
That's so cool, I can't even handle it.
- I end up going to University of Florida,
and I told one of my professors,
I want to work for NASA.
He suggested that I
apply to the NASA Academy
and I remember looking at the
applications and I'm concerned
because you know, English
is my second language,
and at that point I was not gonna send it,
and so my roommate send it for me.
18 students got selected
for the NASA Academy,
I was the only Latin woman in that class.
- I'm convinced that
there are literal angels
because that teacher and your roommate
took that bold step for you.
So I just want to encourage people in life
to help encourage other
people to take bold steps.
You've made it now to NASA,
what is your position right now?
- With Perseverance we're trying to answer
if there was life in the past.
- It seems like the party's over in Mars.
(Diana laughs)
Like everybody's kind
of resting and chilling.
- That's right.
- The Coachella is not happening on Mars.
(Diana laughs)
What happens if you realize, okay,
there was life here before?
- My personal hope is maybe
we'll change our perspective
as humans as to how we treat each other
and how we treat our home planet.
- I mean, doing "E.T."
when I was six years old
is not the impetus for my next comment,
but I am convinced
we're not the only ones.
- I agree. (laughs)
- This is one of the Rovers
that we use to understand
certain things on mobility.
Mikey, would you mind.
- So this is Scarecrow.
- Why did you name it Scarecrow,
is it a "Wizard of Oz" reference?
- It is a "Wizard of Oz"
reference. (Drew claps)
- Ha.
- So, the brains.
- There's no place like home.
That's the big theme
of our show this year.
(TV static)
- This is our sister Rover,
the spare parts of the
actual Perseverance Rover.
- This is the dry run to make
sure you're getting it right
so that when you execute it on Mars,
you have had your practice
and you're going in
really knowing.
- What's gonna happen.
- Exactly. (musical swooshing)
Wow.
(digital beeping)
This is my war games fantasy.
(woman laughs)
Oh my God, I thought I
was about to go through
a hole in the floor but it's not.
- No, this is the center
of the universe. (laughs)
From here we command
lots and lots of missions
that are going to different planets,
Mars missions, and beyond.
This is my baby, the robotic arm on Mars.
- Diana, you are making it your mission
to include the Latinx community.
What is it that you
would like to accomplish?
- I want to take down the expectation
of what women are supposed to be doing.
I have two kids, I'm married,
and I'm also doing this,
so you get to do it all.
- I don't think that there
is a bigger inspiration
out there than you, Diana.
Thank you.
You are truly my hero. (laughs)
(upbeat music)